money-wise this costs me 20 000 a month  to do all right you can scale this down  however you want i also don't have a  tremendous amount of time that i  allocate towards it so i have to  compensate with that with money we have  a twitter editor a youtube editor a  linkedin editor a podcast editor and an  ign ticktock editor and there's two of  us so times two so it's actually 40 000  a month for the both of us the amount of  time that it takes me is two days per  month and four hours per week we do one  day a month of recording for shorts and  then it's usually like a half day i'll  do like four to eight youtube videos  that's how much that's my investment to  do this